bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde nous sommes en direct je suis
ravie de vous retrouver l'actualité ce
soir c'est donc cette sanction maximale
décidée par le Bureau de l'Assemblée à
l'encontre de Grégoire de Fournas ce
député du rassemblement national mise en
cause pour ses propos jugés racistes
hier dans l'hémicycle censure avec
exclusion temporaire validée par un vote
des députés en fin d'après-midi on va y
revenir décision qui tombe au plus mal
pour le RN qui se choisit un nouveau
président demain lors de son congrès à
Paris qu'il retourne en Afrique la pire
polémique au pire moment pour Marine Le
Pen on y revient dans le détail dans
notre grand débat dans un instant avec
nos invités notre grand témoin ce soir
va nous aider à mieux comprendre ce qui
se joue à Kerson ou la situation est
confuse mais surtout très inquiétant
depuis plusieurs jours l'occupant russe
évacue les civils en masse de cette
ville du sud de l'Ukraine annexée pas
pour par Poutine mais où la pression des
forces de Zelenski s'intensifie
offensive ukrainienne imminente ou Piège
tendue par le Kremlin l'analyse du
général trinquant dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission enfin nous
terminerons par niveau de la semaine du
vendredi c'est à la sémiologue Mariette
d'Harry grand comme chaque semaine qu'il
a choisi et ce mot s'est blocage après
les multiples actions coup de poing des
activistes du climat voilà pour le menu
ce soir c'est parti
Grégoire ne Fournas ne pourra donc pas
siéger à l'Assemblée pendant 15 jours
c'est la sanction la plus lourde prévue
par le règlement qui a donc été décidé
par les députés on va y revenir dans le
détail avec trois députés bon soirée
Erwan Balanant député MoDem majorité
macroniste députés du Finistère bonsoir
David Guiraud et bienvenue sur ce
plateau député la France insoumise du
Nord bonsoir Franck alizio bienvenue à
vous député rassemblement national des
Bouches-du-Rhône et puis un journaliste
politique à Marianne va nous rejoindre
dans un tout petit instant c'est Louis
au saleter nous serons également à
distance le voici
Erwan le cœur sociologue des partis
populistes et de l'extrême droite on
reviendra vers vous dans un instant je
vous donne la parole tout de suite mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé cet après-midi
on a besoin de refaire un peu le film
avec vous Stéphane c'est le billet de
Blacko pour ouvrir le bal comme chaque
soir
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
messieurs si j'ai bien compris ce soir
on le répète sur LGP depuis maintenant
les buts l'après-midi le député de
Gironde rassemblement national de
Grégoire de Fournas équipé du maximum
c'est à dire une censure avec exclusion
temporaire ça revient à dire qu'il va
être exclu pendant 15 jours des séances
du parle dans du Parlement et que
pendant deux mois son indemnité sera
réduite de moitié donc c'est une vision
qui a été prise au bureau de l'Assemblée
à l'unanimité en l'occurrence les élus
du début du rassemblement national non
pas participé au vote et il a fallu le
confirmer dans l'hémicycle par un vote
solennel on regarde
et je demande à ceux qui se prononcent
en faveur de la censure avec exclusion
temporaire contre Monsieur de Fournas de
se lever
donc voilà j'ai appris on a fait lever
ce qui était contre et ils étaient bien
moins nombreux donc ce qu'on a souligné
c'est la célérité c'est sanction elle
est assez rare que pour qu'on l'emploie
une seule fois s'était arrivé depuis le
début de la 5e c'était en 2011 avec un
élu communiste avec un tempérament très
volcanique qui avait interrompu une
séance en commission en insultant tout
le monde voilà pour une histoire de
place de voiture et il avait eu cette
sanctions quelle réaction du
rassemblement national après cette
sanction donc décidé à l'unanimité bon
déjà on peut pas dire que vous ayez été
surpris puisque finalement tout les gens
qui participent au bureau de l'Assemblée
avaient annoncé qu'il souhaitait une
sanction très sévère là sanction maximum
bon la réaction d'abord du principal
intéressé il a publié un tweet
immédiatement je propose de regarder où
il dénonce une forme d'injustice
continue de plaider son innocence on
connaît son argumentation il dit que
quand il a crié qu'il retourne en
Afrique il ne visait pas le député
Martin bilango mais le bateau
transportant les migrants dont parlait
ce député donc selon Jean-Philippe
Tanguy le résultat de tout ça c'est que
la sanction qui a été infligée
mon collègue bah c'est une mascarade
alors on écoute son argumentation
parce qu'elle avait cru entendre
retourne en Afrique elle a dit que la
Réunion le bureau devait établir je cite
la matérialité des faits et si il avait
dit retourne en Afrique ou qu'il
retourne en Afrique maintenant on le
sait le compte rendu le dit ceux qui ont
amplifié le son le savent que il a bien
dit qu'il retourne en Afrique en parlant
du bateau l'option de Viking dont était
en train de parler notre collègue
insoumis donc tout ça est une mascarade
alors Marine Le Pen elle va encore plus
loin puisque elle estime en fait que son
députée n'a fait qu'exprimer une opinion
politique en souhaitant que les migrants
qui sont recueillis par des bateaux
humanitaires en Méditerranée soit
retourne en Afrique donc selon moi on a
sanctionné Grégoire de fondation pour
une opinion politique et forcément elle
considère c'est une atteinte à la
démocratie on écoute on la voit pas bien
mais on l'entend
à partir du moment si vous voulez où il
considère que l'idée politique
doit être condamnée et bien on s'éloigne
totalement de la liberté d'expression de
la démocratie
aujourd'hui bon il faut quand même
expliquer que c'est à l'unanimité qui a
été prise cette sanction exactement
alors ça c'était on l'a entendu le score
à peu près tous les groupes qui
voulaient faire qu'on aille le
rassemblement national c'était les
masques tombent le vernis craque on se
les cette idée que finalement le
rassemblement national malgré son
changement d'identité n'est pas très
différent du Front national de
Jean-Marie Le Pen quant à savoir si le
député fournasse parlait de son collègue
insoumis ou du bateau ou du bateau en
fait la plupart des députés pense que ça
n'a pas grande importance même aucune
importance dans le fond donc ils l'ont
dit tous dit exprimer la majorité la
lupestre même les républicains qui sont
pas les plus proches a priori de des
insoumis disent la même chose c'est
Véronique louvagin spécialiste du budget
qui en parlait tout à l'heure
je veux simplement dire que ces propos
considérés en Afrique c'est une honte
absolue au pluriel car balayer d'un
revers de main à la situation de ces
femmes de ces hommes et ses enfants en
danger sur la Méditerranée témoignent
d'un gros regrettable défaut de cœur et
d'humanité
et du côté des insoumis alors j'ai gardé
ça pour la fin donc pour les insoumis
bien ils organiser ce matin un
rassemblement devant l'Assemblée ça a
donné l'occasion Mathilde panneau de
redonner le micro à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui a utilisé ses accents de tribun pour
écouter le appeler la sanction la plus
lourde
il faut que la peine soit proportionnée
à l'acte et la proportion c'est dehors
mais alors ce matin il y avait aussi le
député de Carlos Martins bilango qui
s'est exprimé et moi il me semble que
c'était la partie la plus émouvante de
cette réunion il a remercié l'ensemble
des députés ce qu'ils l'ont soutenu donc
à part les gens du FN la remercie aussi
les Français qui lui ont témoignent leur
soutien et parmi les messages qu'il a
reçu il y a quelque chose qui lui selon
lui très révélateur c'est que c'était
c'est insulte de retourner chez toi
retombe dans ton pays retourne en
Afrique c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas le seul à avoir entendu on écoute
quand il en parle
monsieur Bilingo le député vous avez de
l'argent moi c'est un Sud c'est tous les
jours quand je vais au travail je me
lève à 4h du matin je suis comme de
ménage le travail dans mes différents
restaurateur et continuellement j'ai des
insultes et aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
de pouvoir répondre et d'avoir tous ces
médias en face de moi et j'aimerais vous
dire que des millions de Français des
millions de Français
se font insulter
donc voilà pour le régime des faits bah
maintenant place les bas merci beaucoup
merci Stéphane je vais commencer avec
vous David Giraud hier vous avez eu ces
mots j'attends qu'il dégage avez-vous
dit à propos de Grégoire de Fournas
satisfait ou pas ce soir en tout cas
la majorité de l'Assemblée nationale a
décidé souverainement parce qu'on décide
entre nous aussi des règles qu'on se
donne de dire que les attaques racistes
n'ont pas leur place au sein de
l'assemblée voilà et que peut pas y
avoir d'impunité par rapport à ça et
c'est un geste fort je veux dire il faut
pas le minimiser bien sûr moi je moi
j'estime qu'il devrait pas revenir à
l'Assemblée
je pense même vous savez
beaucoup de collègues qui pensent ça
d'ailleurs pas que de la nupaisse c'est
pas un combat de la nupes ce qui s'est
passé hier soir on en reparlera les
réactions qui a eu instantanées y
compris de Monsieur Balan qui ce qui a
un des premiers à cette levée je tiens
veut dire mais c'est pas une c'est pas
le combat de la nupes c'est juste que
malgré le fait que dans l'assemblée il y
a une liberté d'expression totale qu'on
peut pas être poursuivi en justice peut
pas y avoir d'impunité quand on dit des
choses comme ça des gens et c'est
important de mettre ce signal là moi je
vous le dis je pense que c'est
insuffisant j'aimerais que ça aille loin
mais c'est le mieux qu'on puisse faire
au niveau du Règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale du mandat retirer les vices
présidents de le RN oui ça c'est encore
une autre discussion
à la limite je pense que c'est pas le
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de reconnaître
que cette décision a été prise quel est
forte malgré tout et qu'évidemment on
aimerait aller plus loin alors la
majorité macroniste a fait bloc dès le
début
avec avec les insoumis avec la nupes et
on l'a vu avec les républicains 15 jours
15 jours aucun séances d'affilée il ne
pourra pas siéger il est exclu des
travaux parlementaires pendant 15 jours
on lui coupe de manière moitié ses
indemnités quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit
dehors est-ce que vous aussi vous vous
estimez au fond que c'est pas suffisant
qu'il aurait fallu qu'il démissionne
alors bon je il y a une décision qui a
une décision la maximale que nous
pouvions prendre et je le salue et je
crois qu'on doit le saluer parce que ce
que vient de dire mon collègue Guiraud
c'est que c'est pas le combat
de la nupes c'est le combat de la
République française c'est le combat des
valeurs de la République donc c'est une
sanction c'est une compte-rendu parce
que c'est ça qui fait foi qu'il retourne
en Afrique c'est qu'il au singulier
c'est ce que retient le compte rendu
parce que le compte-rendu mais
évidemment que c'est un système
j'entendais juste avant vous aviez Elsa
fossillon qu'il le disait elle avait les
mêmes propos que moi un peu plus tôt
dans la journée c'est d'une violence
inouïe c'est une violence inouïe moi si
j'étais effectivement le premier à me
lever le premier à crier au scandale
parce que j'étais plus proche et parce
que j'étais épicé mon tempérament c'est
pourquoi parce que j'étais pris au
tripes
j'ai été pris au tripes j'ai eu mal au
ventre en entendant il y a beaucoup de
choses et attendez je continue parce que
maintenant il y a les motion et puis
maintenant il y a la colère il y a la
colère d'avoir un parti qui se dirait
républicain et qui le soutient leur
députés qui a eu ses propos et ses
propos ils sont tes propos qui ont été
tenus dans l'assemblée mais qui ont été
qui ont un historique regardons les
propos de ce député dans ces tweets
précédents alors c'est largement parlé
ici maintenant pour vous c'est
clairement un parti qui n'est pas dans
l'arc républicain c'est encore employer
ce soir par la première minute beaucoup
battus
contre le rassemblement national
qui est accepté de dépit qu'il y a 89
députés parce que c'était la
représentation souveraine populaire d'un
certain nombre d'électeurs je suis
aujourd'hui outré blessé dans mon âme de
républicain de savoir que d'avoir que ce
parti ne je pensais franchement que
Marine Le Pen allait exclure
ce député c'est un parti xénophobe et
raciste parce qu'on entend ces
expressions le vernis craque c'est le
vrai visage du RN qui au fond est enfin
révélée on entend toutes ces expressions
acte isolées racistes pour vous ou
partir raciste
moi j'avoue qu'aujourd'hui je me dis
partir raciste quand j'ai vu que
j'attendais aussi le moment du vote
j'attendais une abstention au moment du
vote quand parce que nous nous avons
voté pour la sanction et j'attendais que
les députés du rassemblement national ne
se votent pas qui vote contre la
sanction ils se sont votés ils se sont
levés ils ont votés contre la sanction
et donc ils assument quelque part ils
soutiennent ces propos racistes et moi
ça me pose des questions très graves
francalizio ça fait deux jours qu'on
entend à la réponse la riposte du
rassemblement national vous allez en
parler j'en suis sûr mais je crois qu'on
a bien compris ce qui a été prononcé
cette parole qu'il retourne en Afrique
est-ce qu'avec deux jours un peu de
recul vous dites pas au moins la façon
dont ces mots ont été prononcés a été
brutal
déjà je vais vous dire ce que je pense
cette décision cette décision est
entachée de mensonge puisqu'elle repose
sur un propos qui n'a pas qui n'a pas
été qui n'a pas été tenu et elle est
entachée de malhonnêteté intellectuelle
donc et cette décision finale est un
délit d'opinion voilà parce que
souhaiter défendre proposer que les
bateaux qui recueillent qui sauvent des
migrants
raccompagne ces migrants en Afrique
c'est une opinion politique c'est une
proposition politique donc c'est un
délit d'opinion
parler d'un procès stalinien moi je
m'étonne mais pourquoi je veux pas la
contester cette décision Franck alizio
il s'y soumet ce soir votre collègue de
Fournas pourquoi dire voilà clairement
non non je ne reconnais pas cette
décision est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un
peu dans la contradiction
il y a une décision
il se l'applique parce que c'est un
député parce qu'il est républicains
parce qu'ils se soumet aux décisions de
son choix de son Assemblée parce qu'il
n'a pas le choix aussi tout à fait parce
qu'il n'a pas le choix je veux dire
c'est les limites à la il y a une limite
il y a il y a pas de recours là-dessus
pourquoi la décision est profondément
injuste et profondément hypocrite en
réalité
à quoi a été condamné un député de votre
majorité qui fait un salut nazi rien
quasiment en tout cas pas la peine
maximale à quoi a été condamné
c'est comparer les affaires à quoi était
condamné monsieur
si vous avez pire vous me le dites à
quoi était condamné monsieur
prazziée qui fait pendant à propos de la
valeur du singe qui tient des propos
clairement nos abons et homophobe alors
peut-être que c'est votre béquille
politique les républicain et que là vous
n'êtes pas monté sur vos grands chevaux
parce que je ne vois que cette
explication ce que veux-tu fradie avait
dit était un qualifiable alors ça c'est
intéressant parce que vous les avez bien
rodés on les entend c'était les mêmes
exactement sur cette chaîne
ville mais rien je pense que
des choses qu'on avait réclamé des
sanctions plus fortes quand c'est
députés mais à la limite c'est pas
l'objet du débat moi je veux revenir sur
quelques affirmations qui tournent
depuis quelques temps on nous dit c'est
un procès stalinien c'est pas un procès
il y a pas de juge il y a pas de
magistrat c'est pas un procès c'est une
décision des députés il y a pas de
défense qui s'ouvrement souverainement
parce qu'ils en ont le droit parce
qu'ils en ont la capacité et les
prérogatives ont décidé d'appliquer une
sanction prévue par le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale dans lequel le
bureau de l'Assemblée a voté à
l'unanimité et dans lesquelles les
députés au sein de l'hémicycle ont voté
à la majorité c'est pas un procès c'est
une décision politique
très rapidement c'est bien la preuve que
vous n'avez pas et c'est une décision
politique
en plus j'ai un peu moins parlé tout à
l'heure mais c'est une décision qui a
été prise par des gens au sein de cette
émission qui hier ont une réaction juste
juste humaine c'est à dire qu'il y a des
on a tous entendu la même chose le
compte-rendu de séance vous savez quand
va-t-il panneau avait été traité de
poissonnière on avait du batailler pour
l'inscrire au compte-rendu et les gens
qui ont fait le compte rendu eux-mêmes
n'étaient pas d'accord entre eux il faut
aussi le savoir donc c'est pas le
compte-rendu le plus important c'est que
tout le monde s'est levé et je vous
assure que quand vous voyez la réaction
des gens et des députés franchement du
MoDem à la France insoumise en passant
par élèvements sur les visages désirs
c'est un compte et je propose je vous
donne la parole vous salitaires dans un
instant mais puisque vous me parlez du
bureau ce qui nous regardent ne
connaissent pas forcément les instances
internes à l'Assemblée nationale bonsoir
Elsa Elsa mandingava vous avez suivi
cette journée à nouveau très tendue dans
l'hémicycle alors expliquez-nous qui
composent ce bureau précisément et
est-ce que vous avez des petites
formation sur les présents et sur la
manière dont il s'est déroulé
aujourd'hui évidemment Myriam alors dans
ce bureau il y a tout d'abord la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a elbron pivée il y a six
vice-présidentes dont deux députés du
rassemblement national Sébastien Chenu
Hélène Laporte il y a les trois
questeurs et aussi 12 secrétaires ça
fait donc 22 membres depuis la réforme
du règlement 2019 les présidents de
groupe ou leur représententrant ont le
droit d'assister aux réunions du bureau
mais ils n'ont pas le droit de vote
voilà ça c'est pour la théorie puisque
tout à l'heure tout le monde n'était pas
présent les kesters par exemple
n'étaient pas présents trois vices
présidents sur 6 manquait à l'appel des
députés étaient en circonscription ils
avaient d'autres obligations il faut
dire que vous le savez c'est un bureau
qui a été un petit peu convoqué hier
soir dans l'urgence ce bureau il s'est
tenu de la manière suivante Grégoire de
fournaise le député a pu exprimer son
opinion il a tenu sa ligne de défense en
disant qu'il parlait d'un bateau Marine
Le Pen la défendu également en disant
que le doute sur ses propos devait lui
être favorable et puis il y a eu les
autres et là il y avait une unanimité
des oppositions et de la majorité
Mathilde panot qui a par exemple pris la
défense de son collègue qui avait été
humilié la majorité les oppositions
elles se sont rapidement mis d'accord
pour pour condamner à la plus haute
sanction on en a parlé la censure avec
exclusion temporaire c'est la plus grave
des sanctions possibles au moment du
vote les députés RN sont sortis du
bureau ils n'ont pas voulu prendre par
robot ils sont venus nous voir celles
des quatre collines ici pour dénoncer et
bien un vote déjà joué d'avance et puis
donc les membres du bureau ont voté à
l'unanimité pour cette sanction la plus
grave qui a été confirmée ensuite dans
l'hémicycle par un vote de tous les
députés qui se sont levés pour
s'exprimer pour et là toutes les
oppositions et la majorité à l'exception
du rassemblement national ce sont levés
et puis le RN a voté contre en se levant
également Grégoire de Fournas a donc été
invité à sortir de Assemblée nationale
si beaucoup Elsa Louis au Salter merci
d'avoir patienté déjà comment vous
analysez au fond cette unanimité dans ce
bureau
nupes LR et la majorité macroniste c'est
ça qui est intéressant et je vais
essayer de pas seulement parler des
dernières 24 heures mais remettre en
perspective avec le début de la
législature depuis le début de la
législature le groupe RN est
insaisissable insaisissable pour ces
adversaires quels qu'ils soient que ce
soit la majorité présidentielle ou la
nuque parce que on a donc 100 fois parlé
de l'arrivée du groupe RN en cravate le
fait qu'il ne fasse pas de bruit pas de
chahut en tout cas au début et puis
surtout leur comportement de vote c'est
à dire voter des dispositions proposées
par le gouvernement votez l'émotion de
censure proposée par l'alliance de la
gauche donc tout ça en fait quelque part
le groupe RN embêtait tout le monde dans
cette émission depuis le début parce que
il est insaisissable à la fois pour la
majorité qui veut pas être prise en
compromission avec un opposant et puis
par la gauche pour lequel la lutte
contre l'extrême droite et le des
combats historiques et là le député de
fondas comme elle l'erreur immense alors
je reviens pas sur le fond des propos
parce qu'on a fait le débat 150 fois
mais stratégiquement c'est quand même
une bêtise immense de ce qu'on portait
comme ça dans l'hémicycle sur le point
même la femme même historique de Marine
Le Pen qui est l'accusation de racisme
l'accusation lancinante de xénophobie il
donne complètement prise à ça et sans
surprise se constitue une alliance
objective de tous ceux qui n'attendaient
que ça que l'erreur d'un députée du
rassemblement national pour ce têtu la
question ça va être comment comment ça
arrondit dans l'opinion en fait tout ça
quelque part vous avez vu le tweet de
Marine Le Pen les Français ne s'y
tromperont pas alors c'est là qu'elle
pose la question en fait comment dans
l'opinion avec le recul ça rebondit
est-ce que les Français qui à mon avis
pour beaucoup d'entre eux voient ce qui
se passe dans l'hémicine de très loin
depuis le début de la satur et pense
quand même que il y a un côté cirque à
tout ça à la fois ce chahut aux postures
de gouvernement y compris à l'attitude
du rassemblement national de jouer les
bons élèves bien policés est-ce qui à
mon avis n'est rarement apprécié par
l'opinion publique qui préfère qu'il y
ait du débat dans la présentation
nationale plutôt que des unanismes de
façade et ben je suis pas sûr qu'en fait
les les personnes qui jouent ce jeu là
elle est en tirent les conclusions
politiques les avantages politiques
qu'elles en attente et je termine par
rassemblement national il est évident
que le comportement de ce députer mais
quand même pas mal en miettes la
stratégie la fameuse stratégie de
respectabilité qui est menée par le RN
pas du tout auprès de son électorat
fidèle qui lui au contraire plutôt
stimuler par cette polémique parce que
ils vont pouvoir jouer le côté
exactement ils vont pouvoir jouer le
côté seul contre tous mais c'était sur
les marges électorales que Marine Le Pen
essaye de grappiller sur c'est sur les
marches qui font basculer une majorité
qui pourrait potentiellement faire
basculer une majorité en 2027 sur les
gens qui quand même gardent ce soupçon
de racisme de xénophobie à l'encontre de
Marine Le Pen et que Marine Le Pen
essayait de faire basculer donc pas du
tout les lectorat traditionnels du
rassemble national et bah c'est
précisément l'électorat qui pourrait
être très troublé par cette polémique
Erwan moi j'aimerais dire préciser
quelques éléments qui sont des éléments
d'ordre juridique qui peuvent paraître
un peu abscons pour les citoyens mais
qui sont importants tout à l'heure vous
avez parlé de procès
pourquoi il faut bien voir les choses
c'est notre statut de parlementaire nous
donne une immunité l'immunité
parlementaire la fameuse unité que voilà
dans tous les cas puisque on a une sorte
de totem pour une plante puisse être
déposées
judiciaire soit même dans l'hémicy non
non même dans l'hémicycle elle est elle
ne peut pas être levée c'est assez
toute la parole c'est la sanctuarisation
de notre parole dans l'hémicycle déjà ça
nous donne une responsabilité ça nous
donne la responsabilité de pas dire
n'importe quoi et je rappelle mon
collègue du Front national c'est que un
citoyen de pardon non à peine pardon
parce que je pense que c'est assez
révélateur de de un citoyen français qui
aurait eu ses propos ce sont des propos
où oui il aurait été jugé il aurait été
jugé au pénal donc il faut arrêter de de
il faut replacer les choses il aurait
été pénalement puni c'est faux vous le
savez
moi pour moi quand vous quand vous dites
qu'il retourne en Afrique et d'ailleurs
le compte rendu n'a pas mis le pluriel
il parlait pas des migrants alors
éventuellement il parlait du bateau mais
j'y crois pas 5 minutes parce que j'y
crois pas 5 minutes parce que au moment
de du déroulé de de du propos oui mais
au moment du déroulé du propos il était
plus question du bateau moi je
m'interroge mais c'est important de le
dire c'est important de le dire et très
clairement elle a pas quand même réagi
tout de suite Marine Le Pen Francky vous
vous pouvez l'admettre certaines
n'étaient pas à l'Assemblée nationale
hier mais quand même elle a envoyé ses
lieutenant elle elle a mis un temps fou
avant de faire ce premier tweet est-ce
que vous trouvez que que c'est un un
soutien franchement appuyé
honnêtement elle a réagi dans la mesure
où elle pouvait où elle pouvait agir il
y a pas de polémique sur le temps
qu'elle a mis à réagir ce
magnifique de dire que de soutenir de
soutenir techniciens et de les soutenir
jusqu'au bout surtout
injustements à accuser ce député vous
avez vraiment mal lu la décision du
Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale parce
que c'est ça qui est extraordinaire je
veux dire vous savez très bien que ce
serait pas au pénal parce que la
décision du Bureau la semaine ne parle
pas de racisme mais parce que parce que
je ne peux pas les condamner
le bureau n'est pas composé
mais on ne peut pas mais même quand il
est condamné
du troubles dans l'assemblée on fait dur
de droit donc c'est pas
l'irresponsabilité
l'inviobilité ce sont deux principes du
droit parlementaire
le député ne peut pas pour ses opinions
et ses propos être condamnés c'est sur
la base d'un autre fondements et sur la
longueur
pour un citoyen de base c'est un nom de
prison 45000 € d'amende un an de prison
45 €
qu'on aille vers lui juste après deux
choses d'abord franchement faut arrêter
de faire semblant c'est vous qui faites
l'homme dont on parle en 2014 quand il
soutient madame Leclerc qui compare qui
compare madame Taubira un singe il sait
ce qu'il fait exactement 2017 tous les
tweets qui fait sur les noirs et les
Arabes c'est obsession arrêtons de faire
semblant 2 secondes maintenant deuxième
chose moi je ne veux pas qu'on laisse
dire et même dans les analyses je pense
que vous faites une erreur d'analyse en
pensant que quelque part on aurait vu la
chose et on aurait sauté dessus en tant
que député pour récupérer le problème ça
ne nous fait pas plaisir ce qui se passe
tout le monde aurait souhaité l'éviter
mais je répète que les gens qui sont
dans l'hémicycle sont aussi des êtres
humains et la plupart n'aiment pas le
racisme et évidemment on s'en met plein
la tête y compris entre monsieur Balan
et moi etc mais le moment où ça arrive
où les gens se lèvent ou Catherine
couturier
Erwan Balanant ou il y a des gens de LR
qui commence à réagir etc au moment où
les gens se lèvent ils ont une réaction
humaine ils ne veulent pas que ça je
vous dis ça parce que je vous assure
qu'il n'y a rien de plus insupportable
je laissais moi parce que c'est
important que ce soit Daniel obono
monsieur Carlos Martins bilongo ils ne
veulent pas exister poétiquement en
raison d'une attaque en fonction de leur
couleur de peau donc encore une fois
nous n'avons aucun intérêt politique à
le faire nous on veut que les gens ils
vivent leur vie et que les députés ils
fassent le boulot pour lequel ils ont
été élus et qu'ils soient reconnus pour
ça
je tiens ce que les gens entendent cet
argument parce que ce n'est pas de la
récupération politique c'est juste une
scène réaction et on n'aime pas le
racisme sur les bancs de cette assemblée
et c'est une bonne chose que de prendre
une sanction disciplinaire prenez-le
comme vous voulez qui est pas pénal mais
la sanction qu'on pouvait prendre à à ce
moment là c'est à dire de lui dire
dehors pendant un certain temps
peut-être pas le temps qu'on aurait
voulu mais dehors parce que ça il y a
pas d'impunité sur ces cas-là bonsoir
Erwan Le cœur et merci d'avoir patienté
avec nous comment vous regardez cet
épisode pendant très très longtemps le
Rassemblement National Front national a
été combattu sur le terrain moral sur le
terrain du cordon sanitaire le No
Pasaran et j'en passe
on revient un peu à cette à cette
manière de le combattre aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est efficace ou pas
non ce n'est pas efficace le plus
exactement ça ne l'a pas été à une
période de l'histoire qui sont depuis
les années 80 et notamment dans les
années 90 ou un certain nombre de partis
politiques de mouvement également on
considérait qu'il fallait combattre le
Front national de l'époque sur le plan
moral sur le plan de l'anti-racisme et
malheureusement sans aucun doute et il a
souvent été cas ils ont été capables de
monter tout un tas de choses autour de
ce thème mais pas grand chose à côté et
c'était un des principaux problèmes on
l'a analysé de nombreuses chercheurs
leur analysé depuis le principal
problème c'est que le le pénis puisqu'il
faut l'appeler comme tel la parole le
pénis qui portait celle du Front
national il y avait un seul porte-parole
et c'était monsieur puis Madame Le Pen
apportait bien au-delà des limites de la
morale et la morale en politique et là
ce à quoi on assiste si je peux me
permettre c'est quand même au choc de
monde qui sont différents il y a un
monde dont Monsieur de Fournas et un peu
l'archétype c'était un monde c'est un
quelqu'un de la Gironde un type du cru
un type qui parle à ses électeurs qui
est un militant qui est convaincu de ce
qu'il dit que les gens doivent retourner
en Afrique parce que ça fonctionne dans
son monde à lui dans son référentiel
culturel à lui je dirais et là le
sociologue que je suis ne peut pas
s'empêcher pour avoir fait de nombreuses
entretiens avec des militants du Front
national pour ma thèse de reconnaître
cela de dire mais ces gens-là ils vivent
dans un monde où on a le droit de dire
ces choses là où
à la l'issue du repas ou même dans une
discussion on a le droit on se le permet
parce qu'on est entre nous on est dans
un entre soi et en Europe on voit bien
ce que l'on reçoit en Suède en Italie
dans d'autres pays est en train de
provoquer c'est-à-dire un entre soi
contre le reste du monde et puis là on a
eu un choc de culture parce que cette
personne est devenue députée elle ne s'y
attendait absolument pas on a 89 députés
qui sont pour la plupart des novices en
politique absolue qui n'ont pas du tout
de et c'est pour ça que Marine Le Pen
leur a dit vous vous taisez s'il vous
plaît surtout surtout ne faites pas de
ne cassez pas ma stratégie de
normalisation président
formation potentielles on a dépassé la
dédiabolisation dans une normalisation
voir une institutionnalisation c'est à
dire le Front national de venir
rassemblement national voudrait
maintenant prendre la gueuse de l'époque
puisque c'était la République c'était la
gueuse qu'il fallait prendre et pas
toujours bien et maintenant devenir
républicain plus que tout le monde plus
Assemblée nationale peut les gens de LFI
parce que nous on porte une cravate
dit-il etc et là on a eu un choc de
culture sur lequel en effet comme ça
vient d'être dit les députés se sont dit
mais c'est pas possible il y a un
problème il ne peut pas dire ça à
l'Assemblée nationale merci je
reviendrai vers vous et puis il y a
cette motion de censure l'eau saletaire
on aurait pu imaginer Frank alizio que
vous ne méruriez pas vos voix à ceux qui
voudraient de racistes et pourtant vous
l'avez fait vous allez vous vous en
expliquer on va écouter Elisabeth borne
à l'issue des débats sur cette motion de
censure tout à l'heure écoutez la
première ministre
je l'ai dit et je le répète je ne
confonds pas la France insoumise et le
rassemblement national
c'est un jour abject nous rappelle
pourquoi
aussi je me réjouis de voir enfin
l'extrême droite rejetée dans le texte
de la motion de censure à soumise et
pourtant une fois de plus cet après-midi
les voies du rassemblement national se
joindront à celle de la France insoumise
alors on va commencer par le décryptage
et puis vous donnerez votre raison
pourquoi font-ils ça
c'est une bonne stratégie ou pas
après une journée pareille toute la
stratégie est de déjà cible LR il s'agit
de montrer que la droite et la fameuse
béquille du gouvernement et que donc le
gouvernement ce qui est vrai d'ailleurs
dans les faits dans l'hémicycle ne tient
que parce que les LR ne votent pas une
motion de censure après il y a un bal
des faux semblant qui est quand même
assez généralisé voir un bal des faux
cul parce que le gouvernement
sous-entend ou même d'ailleurs le
sous-entend de moins en moins que il y a
cette alliance des extrêmes que les
populistes se rejoignent enfin je vous
ressors pas toutes les formules un petit
peu éculées tout simplement parce que le
rassemblement journal vote une motion de
censure de la nuque mais ce n'est pas de
la faute de la nuque si les voies du
rassemblement national se portent sur sa
motion de censure qui veut la vote c'est
la règle
du point de vue du RN c'est la règle
dans l'hémicycle à mêlée
ce soir c'est de en fait Marine Le Pen
joue quand même une possibilité un jour
de dissolution en tout cas de changement
de gouvernement donc de renversement du
gouvernement de dissolution
éventuellement conséquent exactement et
elle pense que c'est elle qui en tirera
les marrons du feu et un sondage
intéressant dans le JDD de dimanche
dernier alors peut-être que l'affaire
fanas va rebattre les cartes mais qui
montre que Marine Le Pen si on rejoue à
la présidentielle serait devant Emmanuel
Macron cette fois donc elle pense elle
que à court terme elle peut tirer des
marrons du feu si les français étaient
appelés à revenir aux urnes moi je ne
précise pas de ça surtout après ce qui
vient de se passer mais la stratégie en
tout cas c'est de montrer que le
rassemble national qui serait prêt à
gouverner la conséquence et il est aussi
prêt à faire tomber un gouvernement
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'ailleurs le même
propos francalizio aucun problème ce
soir à avoir voté la motion déposée par
les insoumis nous avons reçu un mandat
de nos électeurs ce mandat c'est
s'opposer à Emmanuel Macron et si
possible le faire tomber voilà nous
sommes des options le plus
intelligemment possible voilà mais
s'opposer voilà donc lorsque
je pourrais terminer d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on s'oppose on saisit toutes les
cas toutes les occasions de s'opposer
nous nous voyons une motion de censure
on va pas forcément qu'il a écrit tout
qu'il apporte on sait que cette motion
de censure n'a strictement aucune chance
de de réussir de censurer le
gouvernement de le faire tomber si nous
ne la vendons pas donc en responsabilité
nous la votons nous nous prouvons par là
d'ailleurs que nous pèse du coup sans
les idiots utiles de ce gouvernement
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas de notre
voix donc ils ne veulent pas que leur
motion soit votée
ils ne veulent pas que le gouvernement
tombe c'est ça qui ridicule donc les
républicains eux au moins ils sont on
sait qu'ils sont pas les yeux utiles ils
sont les utiles du gouvernement les
républicains prennent leurs électeurs
comme pour
idiot c'est pour ça qu'ils ont de moins
en moins mais vous vous êtes
idiots de gouvernement n'est pas
renversé ce soir mais vous auriez pu
changer votre texte et écrire le RN est
repartir raciste à ce moment-là je pense
pas que le RN aurait voté cette motion
pourquoi vous l'avez pas voté si on
l'avait pas fait en effet mais non on
n'entend pas arrêté notre activité
parlementaire je crois que c'est assez
clair que notre opposition rassemblement
nationale est totale et j'ai pas envie
si vous voulez en plus je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait une unité qui
était assez intéressante quand même
contrôler racisme moi j'ai pas envie de
faire de la polémique là dessus c'est
comme si je disais bah Darmanin il a
qu'à dire que dans son texte sur
l'immigration l'extrême droite est
raciste comme ça le RN vote pas fin
franchement on peut durer très longtemps
par contre juste d'un point de vue
démocratique la motion de censure elle
est faite pour être votée pas pour
témoigner
voilà je le dis donc si vous voulez
c'est juste que c'est pas fait pour
témoigner une motion de censure et nous
ne sommes pas maître du vote des députés
du rassemblement donc nous nous quand on
dit mais c'est un enjeu démocratique il
y a pas autre chose que l'enjeu
démocratie
on n'a pas voté celle du rassemblement
national parce que dans son exposé des
motifs par contre il y avait des
questions relatives à l'immigration avec
lesquelles on était en totale désaccord
faut quand même réaliser qu'il
intervient à la veille de votre congrès
focaliser c'est quand même un calendrier
particulier depuis un mois les 40 000
adhérents du rassemblement national ont
voté par voie électronique pour
départager le grand favori Jordan
bardeira Bardella qui affronte Louis
Aliot portrait croisé signé Marion
Becker on en parle juste après
après 50 ans de règne dès le Pen à la
feuille de route est claire une seule
ligne celle tracée par Marine Le Pen
tout en renforçant le vernis de
respectabilité du parti pour l'incarner
deux hommes vont s'affronter et d'un
côté Jordan Bardella la nouvelle
génération
à 27 ans c'est le dauphin il n'est pas
encore majeur quand il rencontre Marine
Le Pen en 2016 elle le façonne et trois
ans plus tard le propulse tête de liste
aux Européennes depuis
l'ambitieux ne laisse rien au hasard
soigne son image dans son duo avec
Marine Le Pen à lui le fils d'immigrés
italienne elle est sortie
identitaire quitte à flirter avec les
idées d'Éric Zemmour
oui un basculement démographique qui
pourrait faire craindre que la France ne
change de visage dans quelques années et
c'est déjà en train d'arriver parce que
moi je me souviens lorsque le prix du
grand basculement mais je n'aime pas ce
mot de grand emplacement parce que je
trouve qu'il n'est pas clair c'est un
slogan très intellectuel mais il pointe
une réalité qui est juste une expression
pourtant bannie par Marine Le Pen c'est
clin d'oeil de Jordan Bardella à la
frange identitaire Louis Aliot son
distingue dans un entretien au journal
Le Monde il dit craindre un retour en
arrière ou une pause dans cette
évolution loin des obsessions
identitaires du parti bref il redoute
que la normalisation du rassemblement
national soit remise en cause par son
adversaire à 53 ans Louis Aliot joue la
carte de l'expérience celle d'un élu
local mais aussi celle d'un homme
montrait au Front national en 1990 sous
Jean-Marie Le Pen mais qui a su prendre
ses distances avec le patriarche pour
devenir un partisan et un acteur de la
dédiabolisation engagée depuis 10 ans
deux hommes deux profils pour une
élection jouée d'avance dont l'enjeu est
surtout l'image car derrière ce futur
président un nul doute que la figure
centrale restera Marine Le Pen
Erwan Le coeur vous qui suivez
attentivement le rassemblement national
et ses évolutions il y a deux lignes à
travers ces deux candidats non il y a
une ligne c'est celle de Marine Le Pen
ça c'est la première chose elle a réussi
à trouver deux candidats qui pouvaient
s'opposer sans se combattre c'est le
deuxième chose cette famille politique
c'est assez rare et quand il se
combattent en général ça peut aller très
très loin souvenez-vous de Maigret et
quelques autres et puis la troisième
chose il y a une ligne mariniste qui est
claire qui n'est plus la dédiabilisation
qui est une normalisation avancée qui
est même désormais une
présidentialisation Jordan Bardella est
le bon candidat pour une raison simple
il ne lui fait pas d'ombre encore il est
encore jeune et surtout il va tenir la
frange que comme sur votre reportage là
très bien dit la frange la plus dure
tandis que elle pourra apparaître comme
plus souple et donc plus présidentiable
à la tête des députés
au niveau du rassemblement national
exactement c'est à dire qu'il y a un con
une complémentarité qui se fera entre le
jeune homme qui tiendra une partie du
zemmourïsme sur le fond mais qui tiendra
surtout le parti et qui en expulsera les
gens qui éventuellement se régénant
comme l'avait fait Louis Alliot surtout
il a expulsé beaucoup de monde du Front
national les plus durs on était mis
dehors par Louis alu à l'époque
aujourd'hui c'est le c'est le temps de
c'est le 12 c'est celui qui a Perpignan
c'est l'ancien compagnon de Marine Le
Pen et donc quelque part ça ferait
doublon avec Marine Le Pen donc là il y
a une répartition des rôles un pas de 2
qui est assez intéressant et puis il
faut le dire vous l'avez dit le Congrès
a lieu demain et cette affaire de
l'Assemblée nationale tombe finalement
plutôt bien pour un congrès puisque vous
le savez au sein du parti tout cela va
ressouder les trous autour de l'image et
de l'idée que le Front national devenu
rassemblement national est toujours bel
et bien la victime du système politique
et cela demain ils vont s'en donner à
cœur joie sans aucun doute d'une
certaine façon la personne
gentiment sourire c'est du miel pour
vous cette analyse parce qu'elle est
vraie
cette union
derrière cette stratégie ces diabolique
ces diaboliques et vous venez de le
faire vous venez de faire l'aveu vous
venez de parler de propos vous venez de
dire ces bateaux et on sait qu'on va les
accueillir et oui voilà
70 % des Français mais vous n'êtes pas
contre l'immigration c'est pas le sujet
l'immigration le sujet je crois que
c'est que vous êtes ontologiquement
raciste tout simplement et j'ai
franchement et je suis aujourd'hui
extrêmement inquiet et on va se battre
moi je vais continuer le combat je l'ai
j'ai commencé je suis rentré en
politique je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
lors d'une manifestation de de Maigret à
Rennes quand j'étais étudiant et je
continuerai parce que la République les
valeurs de la démocratie on les a
construits et on va les et on va aller
puis je vous donnerai le mot de la fin
de vos salaires ce débat sur le fond
parce qu'après tout la question elle a
été posée par votre collègue insoumis
vous vous avez poussé le gouvernement à
vous à se positionner sur le fait qu'il
faut accueillir cette Ocean Viking ce
bateau il faut l'avoir ce débat malgré
ce qui progresser ou pas bien sûr et
avec nos désaccords c'est juste qu'on
n'aime pas les racistes et que si vous
aussi on a chez vous qui redit une
phrase raciste on le sortira pareil
il y en a une qui a fini il y en a une
qui a conclu le débat parmi nous c'est
madame louvagi qui est quand même pas le
monstre bolchevik hein c'est les
républicains commissions des finances
c'est quelqu'un vraiment qui est pas du
solide sur notre option et c'est vrai
qui est plutôt respectable qui a dit une
chose qui est tout aussi juste c'est que
on parle de gens qui sont en train de
mourir d'accord qui sont dans un dans
une situation de danger extrême avec des
femmes enceintes etc mais que l'on peut
penser ce que l'on veut de ce bateau on
peut penser ce que l'on venait tous les
sauver que par contre dire comme ça de
les renvoyer balayer d'un revers de main
leur situation ça aussi c'est ça
va rester ce qui s'est passé bah je
pense que quand il y aura des projets de
loi immigration justement extra discuté
au début de l'année prochaine à
l'Assemblée on sera pas du tout dans la
même tonalité dans le même unanimisme
dans les mêmes types de prise de parole
je pense la MAJ sera plus embarrassé
parce que cette fois c'est le RN qui
viendra apporter ses voix peut-être à
certaines dispositions et que du coup on
sera pas du tout dans la même il y a
déjà des amendements
sur ce projet de loi qui vont vraiment
quand il était adopté voilà merci
Monsieur Merci beaucoup merci à
Erwan lecœur à distance avec nous je
signale que l'étrange victoire avec
Agathe Lambret Macron II l'histoire
secrète aux éditions l'Observatoire est
toujours dans les bonnes librairies oui
au sale terre merci à vous on va
s'arrêter à présent sur la situation à
Kerson en Ukraine avec notre grand
témoin le général trinquant depuis
plusieurs jours l'occupant russe
s'évacue les civils en masse de cette
ville du sud de l'Ukraine annexée par
Poutine mais où la pression des forces
de volodières zellens qui s'intensifie
alors offensive ukrainienne imminente ou
Piège tendue par le Kremlin le point
carte adapté avec Marco pommier avant
d'accueillir notre invité
cela ressemble à une opération imposée
depuis plusieurs jours à Carson dans le
sud de l'Ukraine l'occupant russe
s'évacue les civils en masse des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
concernées un couvre-feu 24 heures sur
24 vient même d'être annoncé les troupes
de Moscou se préparent à une offensive
ukrainienne imminente ce qui vivent
actuellement à Kerson doivent être
éloignés des zones de combat les plus
dangereuses il ne devrait pas souffrir
des bombardements depuis un mois la
pression des forces ukrainiennes sur
Carson s'intensifie mais après huit mois
d'occupation russe l'armée de Vladimir
Poutine pourrait se retirer et quitter
la rive-occidentale à l'ouest du pays
pour rejoindre la rive orientale le
drapeau russe a été retiré du principal
bâtiment administratif de la Ville sur
ces images les Russes évacuent une
partie de leur matériel lourd
confirmation sur ses photos satellites
autour de l'aérodrome on observe des
emplacements vidés de leur véhicule et
quand les Russes fuient les colonnes de
son armée sont pris sous le feu
ukrainien je ne peux plus t'entendre
j'ai une commotion
mince
foutons le camp de là
réel aveux de faiblesse de Vladimir
Poutine ou retrait en trompe l'oeil les
Ukrainiens craignent un piège militaire
a commencé par la porte-parole de
l'armée il pourrait s'agir d'une
provocation afin de créer l'impression
que ces endroits sont abandonnés qu'on
peut y pénétrer en sécurité alors que
les Russes se préparent à des batailles
de rue la reconquête de kersen par les
Ukrainiens serait un symbole politique
mais aurait aussi une importance
stratégique sa perte pourrait ouvrir à
l'Ukraine la voie vers la mère d'Azov
vitale sur le plan commercial cela
pourrait aussi menacer la main mise de
Moscou sur la Crimée annexée depuis 2014
volody mirzelinski souhaiterait faire
revenir la péninsule dans le giron
ukrainien
bonsoir général trinquant et merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ancien chef d'admission
militaire française au sein des Nations
Unies à New York alors les images qui
nous parviennent de Kerson montrent des
évacuations massives en cours orchestrée
par le régime du Kremlin il faut
expliquer que pour Poutine Carson c'est
depuis le 37 septembre un excès donc
c'est la Russie qu'est-ce qu'on sait sur
ces évacuations précisément alors les
évacuations ont lieu depuis plusieurs
semaines
initialement elles étaient ont demandé
aux gens de partir ensuite on a dit au
pro russe d'évacuer absolument et puis
maintenant il y a un couvre-feu qui est
installé il y a un régime spécial qui
s'installe et on veut sortir toute la
population de Kerson donc pour les
prorus ça veut dire d'une certaine façon
que personne est abandonné
alors abandonner pour des combats ou pas
on pourra en parler après pour les
pro-ukrainiens ce sont des déportations
de population qui sont envoyés en
territoire contre les par les Russes
comme ça se fait depuis un petit moment
voilà alors c'est toujours difficile de
se mettre dans la tête de Vladimir
Poutine vous vous dites ce choix d'un
retrait c'est pour déguiser au fond une
difficulté militaire sur le terrain
indéniable à Carson et la déguisé en
manoeuvre c'est ça oui alors ce que je
dis d'abord voyons à quoi
servez personne personne a été saisi
dans les premiers jours de mars très
rapidement par surprise par les forces
qui arrivaient de Crimée et qui ont pris
Kerson et le but était de continuer vers
Nicolas heiffe et Odessa de toute façon
voilà à l'ouest de façon à pouvoir avoir
contrôler toute la mer Noire en fait
tous les ports les débouchés de
l'Ukraine
en fait les armée russe n'ont jamais
réussi à conquérir nicolaïf et
aujourd'hui elles savent très bien
qu'elles ne pourront jamais aller au
dessin en plus la marine russe n'arrive
pas à mettre un blocus sur au dessin
puisqu'elle est tirée par des drones à
partir de ça donc la bataille de Carson
est perdue d'avance
ça veut dire que personne ne sert plus à
rien
ensuite Kerson c'est sur le Nieppe et
les forces russes sont actuellement sur
la rive droite du niap 1 vers l'ouest
dure
avec un diamètre de large qui peut faire
jusqu'à 1000 mètres et puis il y a des
retenues d'eau qui font encore plus loin
donc être d'un côté ou de l'autre ça
change beaucoup ça change complètement
et donc Kerson pour Poutine c'est un peu
Stalingrad c'est à dire que on doit se
battre on doit tenir seulement il y a
quelques semaines déjà les chefs
militaires lui ont dit non il faut qu'on
décroche de Kerson parce qu'on
n'arrivera pas à tenir à Carson un
nouveau chef a été nommé pour commander
l'ensemble des opérations sa première
déclaration a été dire la situation
étendue il faudra prendre des décisions
difficiles alors je ne sais pas ce que
vont faire les Russes mais moi je sais
ce que je le recommanderais de faire et
je leur recommanderais de quitter Kerson
pour s'installer sur la rive gauche du
niep le Nieppe faisant un barrage
antichard un faux c'est antichard
naturel
et de là avec l'artillerie etc ils
peuvent tirer sur les Ukrainiens de
l'autre côté en étant pas menacé
directement par des attaques terrestres
c'est ce qui semble se passer puisque
aujourd'hui les ponts qui ont été
bombardés par les Ukrainiens ont été
remplacés par des systèmes
tactiques j'allais dire et l'artillerie
les PC le gouvernement qui était sur la
rive droite du Nieppe et passer sur la
gauche donc ça semble prendre cette
comment va-t-il faire comprendre ça
Poutine à sa population qu'elle
propagande alors quels moyens de
communication extrêmement difficile mais
je pense que politiquement personne est
pardon militairement Kerson est perdu
donc qu'est-ce qu'il vaut mieux annoncer
une défaite militaire à Kerson des
troupes russes prisonnières qui ne
peuvent pas franchir le niep ou annoncer
qu'on a monté une manœuvre pour
interdire l'accès au territoire conquis
à partir du niep
compliqué à monter sur le plan de la
communication mais je pense que les
trois
rideau de fumée qui ont été mis depuis
plusieurs semaines un évacuation de la
population on s'occupe des populations
voyez deux le barrage va sauter c'est
les Ukrainiens qui vont le faire sauter
il y a toujours pas sauter 3 il y a une
bombe sale qui va être mis en place par
les Ukrainiens la IEA vient de faire son
rapport en disant il y a rien de préparé
ces trois rideau de fumée sont faits
pour masquer cette défaite à Carson et
maintenant il faut embrayer la
communication en disant on arrête tout
on arrête les Ukrainiens une franchiront
pas le Nieppe
de Carson il y a des bombardements
depuis plusieurs jours sur des
infrastructures et il y a l'hiver qui
arrive est-ce que l'objectif de Poutine
mise en difficulté dans cette région sud
du Dombasle c'est pas aussi de couper
toute forme d'énergie aux Ukrainiens
avec l'arrivée de l'hiver on sait que
l'hiver il y a des pluies il y a des
bouts les conflits en bourbe alors je
pense que l'objectif de Poutine il est
de deux ordres sur le plan opératif
prenant en termes militaire c'est-à-dire
l'opération en Ukraine il est
d'affaiblir la population
ukrainienne de façon à ce qu'elle
soutiennent moins les forces armées et
la résistance sur le plan stratégique
c'est d'affaiblir le soutien à l'Ukraine
et le soutien à l'Ukraine c'est qui ce
sont les États-Unis et les Européens il
attend quoi les mitormélections la
semaine prochaine les républicains sont
dit voilà les républicains ont dit si
nous gagnons on arrête de payer pour la
défense à l'Ukraine donc ça c'est le
premier soutien deuxième soutien c'est
les Européens si les Américains se
retirent tout retombent sur les
Européens et les Européens le poids va
être encore plus lourd est-ce que les
États européens vont être capables de
tenir le soutien l'Ukraine et plus grave
que ça est-ce que les populations
européennes
dans le discours que le président
Poutine a fait en salle Saint-Georges
vous souvenez il y a quelques deux
semaines maintenant
il s'est adressé directement à nos
populations quand il a employé les
termes de parents de parents de etc
c'était les Françaises qu'il attaquait
donc ça veut dire qu'il veut enfoncer le
coin entre l'Ukraine et ses soutiens
européens et américains mais il veut
aussi enfoncer le coin dans nos
populations dans notre société en disant
vous n'avez quand même pas soutenir ça
vous pourquoi auriez-vous froid c'est le
problème des Ukrainiens c'est pas votre
problème
stratégique dans les jours qui viennent
avec les élections américaines
évidemment à regarder de très près
Carson c'est aussi stratégique parce que
c'est pas loin de la Crimée il y a eu
l'effondrement du pont l'explosion et
puis ces attaques de drone récentes côté
ukrainien comment les occidentaux les
Américains regardent cette ambition
ukrainienne de reprendre ou de tenter de
reprendre la Crimée est-ce que c'est
rouge ou pas alors c'est très difficile
et je vais me faire haïr par tous les
ukrainiens et les pro Ukrainiens
qu'aux reconquérir jusqu'au frontières
de 2014 je pense que les Ukrainiens peut
le faire et ils seront soutenus par
l'ensemble de la communauté qui les
soutient aujourd'hui la Crimée va être
un vrai sujet la Crimée est un vrai
sujet pourquoi parce qu'en 2014 il y a
eu quand même une réponse assez mièvre
des Européens et des Américains
là-dessus il y a eu quelques mesures de
prises mais pas grand chose et donc le
président Poutine peut dire aujourd'hui
bah ils ont pas tellement réglé en 2014
pourquoi aujourd'hui réagirait et
l'Ukraine reste une terre russe donc je
pense que c'est le dernier lieu sur
lequel il pourrait y avoir et je
rappelle que lors des premières
négociations à Istanbul entre les
ukrainiens et ça devait être en avril
entre les ukrainiens et les Russes la
position ukrainienne qui avait été
admise ok neutralisation de l'Ukraine
elle ne rentrera pas dans l'OTAN mais en
revanche
on pourra discuter des limites
territoriales pendant 15 ans
alors aujourd'hui évidemment maintenant
les
Ukrainiens sont dans une phase offensive
ils gagnent le rapport de force à
changer ils ont complètement changé
est-ce que tous leurs soutien et si les
Américains les lâchent ça les pousserait
à quand même regarder à deux fois dans
un premier temps je dis pas que sur le
long terme il le gagnera pas mais c'est
avoir j'ai vu un document très
intéressant qui est le document
franco-allemand proposé aux Européens
sur quelle position avoir vis-à-vis de
la Russie et il est très clair il est
défait de la Russie défaites non
seulement Ukraine mais stratégiquement
en Bosnie-Herzégovine ailleurs partout
défaire tant que le gouvernement
Ukraine russe n'aura pas changé sa
position puisque aujourd'hui il est dans
une position de guerre globale contre le
client
veut plus en Occident en Europe répéter
des erreurs du passé j'ai bien compris
il y a des toujours cette menace
nucléaire certains disent que des
évacuations serait peut-être le prélude
à une à une menace les Américains
Divia par voie de presse qui a eu un
briefing de Joe Biden sur le caractère
sérieux de cette menace de Poutine
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez non je
pense qu'il faut toujours prendre au
sérieux la menace nucléaire c'est une
évidence sur le fond j'entends dire tout
et son contraire moi je ne crois pas à
une frappe nucléaire pour raison simple
c'est que le jour Poutine utilise l'arme
nucléaire mettons sur Carson même une
arme tactique c'est une arme tactique
c'est Hiroshima quand même c'est majeur
et bien l'Inde
la Chine tous les supporters vont bannir
Poutine il commettra ce que personne
n'ose imaginer aujourd'hui je pense que
politiquement c'est trop fort trop fort
et puis au bout du compte je dis
toujours qu'entre le doigt de Poutine
qui dit il faut appuyer sur le bouton et
celui qui appuie sur le bouton il y a
quand même quelques échelons et je suis
pas persuadé que le dernier qui a envie
aurait envie de mourir sous une bombe
nucléaire merci infiniment de venir
régulièrement sur ce test pour nous
éclairer sur ce conflit majeur au cœur
de l'Europe je vous propose de rester
avec moi on va accueillir pour terminer
cette émission Mariette d'arrêt grand
Marielle darrigran vous le savez
désormais c'est notre sémiologue comme
chaque vendredi est choisi un mot un mot
dans l'actualité qu'elle décortique et
ce mot ce soir c'est le mot blocage on
l'accueille tout de suite bonsoir
Mariette bonsoir vous vouliez revenir
sur ces nouveaux activistes du climat
qui ont l'écologie de combat radicale en
bandoulière pour pour nous parler de ce
mot de blocage oui parce que je crois
qu'il lui donne un peu un autre sens
alors cette semaine j'ai été intéressée
même un peu émue par une scène vue à la
télé comme on dit puis ensuite va sur
les réseaux ou envoyer un jeune policier
qui décolle littéralement une jeune
activiste de le du groupe dernière
rénovation alors je dis décoller parce
que elle s'était effectivement
engluée un collait vraiment les mains au
bitume et donc du coup ça m'a fait
réfléchir au sens de bloquer parce que
là c'est vraiment un sens très concret
d'habitude quand on bloque des gens
bloquent une usine ou bloque une
raffinerie comme il y a il y a peu c'est
le blocage en fait est un mouvement une
agitation et cela peut aller jusqu'à la
violence ce qu'on appelle très bien les
Blacks blocs il faut entendre le bloc
dans son sens premier ça vient de la du
vocabulaire de la maçonnerie les blocs
ce sont les pierres en fait que avec
lesquels on bâtit une maison et donc
c'est intéressant parce que les Black
Bloc sur le contraire au lieu de
construire la maison ils peuvent prendre
des blocs de pierres ou des pavés ou des
objets sur les forces de l'ordre et
c'est différent des activités de
l'écologie radicale ben oui parce que
ces activistes là ce gros plat prône la
non-violence donc si c'est un peu comme
s'il retournait la violence contre eux
et comme si le blocage il en faisait
leur affaire c'est eux-mêmes qui les
bloque c'est de l'autoblocage on
pourrait dire alors c'est peut-être pour
dire que Ben aussi solidifie comme ça je
ne sais pas mais on aurait pu s'attendre
au contraire puisque il dénonce
l'immobilisme de l'État donc on aurait
pu s'entendre ils sont tous très jeunes
ils auraient pu courir très vite autour
de la place de la Concorde dénoncer les
assis comme disait rimbauds ces gens qui
pas l'arbres tous un peu vieux qui pas
l'arbre et puis qui n'agissent au
contraire avec de la glue que ce soit
sur un tableau ou alors dans des dans
des garages on l'a vu récemment c'est
l'immobilier il y a un paradoxe dans
cette attitude là vous vous le voyez oui
je pense qu'il y a un paradoxe ça se
fixer pour dé de la fixité mais je pense
qu'il y a quand même aussi autre chose
en dessous Myriam qui concerne au
premier chef les journalistes parce que
je crois qu'ils veulent quand ils
veulent bloquer quelque chose c'est le
flow médiatique parce que le flux
médiatique et bah il est pas bloqué ou
au contraire il est permanent il est
tout le temps là mais il est
complètement composite il mélange tout
une
Ukraine le tragique de la guerre mais
aussi la dernière info pipeau un fait
divers enfin ou un incident comme on a
vu aujourd'hui ou hier à l'Assemblée
tout ça est mélangé et donc du coup il
n'y a pas d'aspérité or eux leur grande
cause c'est l'urgence climatique donc
ils ont l'impression qu'elle va
disparaître donc je pense que c'est pour
cela que la le blocage pour eux c'est
une façon de de d'isoler un morceau du
flot médiatique de le solidifier en
quelque sorte de nous le montrer de le
faire émerger donc c'est un zoom sur un
détail de la grande fresque c'est
j'oserais dire que c'est un arrêt sur
image un arrêt sur blocage donc on peut
comprendre la logique évidemment il y a
deux grands dangers le premier vous avez
parlé des musées bah c'est que ce soit
le vandalisme débile personnellement je
pense et mais aussi plus gravement c'est
le danger de récupération politique et
là justement la violence de certains
professionnels du blocage et bien
évidemment elle est très grande merci
beaucoup marriette j'imagine que ça vous
choque d'une poignée de seconde c'est
ses actions de blocage
j'ai trouvé ça excellent le
concessionnaire qui a laissé les gens
coller au sol ce qui fait la fin de
l'histoire merci beaucoup merci Mariette
et Merci à VOUS général trinquant vous
êtes le bienvenue vous le savez quand
vous voulez très belle soirée
documentaire avec Jean-Pierre graffien
c'est le week-end merci à toute l'équipe
qui m'a accompagné encore une belle
semaine au programme et à la semaine
prochaine profitez bien